wanda vision is finally here and it
isn't like anything we've seen before
in the mcu except of course for the
usual treasure trove of references to
the comics and
other marvel movies here are the easter
eggs you may have missed in the first
two episodes of one division
as soon as preview images began popping
up for one division it became clear the
show was taking part of its inspiration
from a fan favorite but short-lived
comic book series
in early 2016 marvel comics released the
first issue of tom king
and gabriel hernandez walta's vision the
symphysoid had enjoyed a couple of
miniseries before then
but this one was unique this vision
comic also found its title character
trying to build an idyllic and ordinary
life in a quiet suburb
rather than being married to scarlet
witch however vision builds his family
of synthesoids
his wife virginia his son vin and his
daughter viv
unlike the heroes of wandavision the
synthezoid and his family make no
attempt to hide what they are in the
vision comic
which leads to more than a few
complications no spoilers but here's
hoping one division has a happier ending
the style of the first episode of
wandavision is based on sitcoms of the
50s
and early 60s and the faux intro
includes a funny easter egg calling back
to one of those classic programs
the dick van dyke show the reference
isn't so much about what happens though
as much as it is about what doesn't
happen fans of the dick van dyke show
will likely notice the similarity in
theme music with wandavisions
they'll also remember that in some
episodes of the dick van dyke show the
intro includes the titular star tripping
over the ottoman in his living room and
taking a tumble there was also an
alternate version used occasionally
where dick sidesteps the ottoman
in one division's intro vision almost
finds himself making the same mistake
as he's carrying wanda into their living
room unlike van dijk however
vision's powers allow him to phase right
through the precariously placed
furniture
and deliver wanda to the living room
without injury
laughing at people in pain is a
manifestation of a deep deep-seated
hostility
there's a lot of twin imagery in the
first two episodes of wandavision
usually in the form of matching sets of
jewelry furniture and
other objects and in some cases the
matching pair is missing
for example when agnes introduces
herself to wanda she notices wanda
doesn't wear a wedding ring
though wanda takes care of this toward
the end of the episode
there's also the two lobsters that wanda
accidentally sends flying out of her
kitchen window
that subsequently vision can't find
there's the couple's twin beds
and other twin sets of furniture and
even the matching pieces of toast
in the toastmate 2000 commercial ever
since the first trailer for the
wandavision miniseries dropped
there's been speculation that it would
involve wanda maximoff's
twin sons billy and tommy from the
comics both of whom
ultimately proved to be constructs of
wanda's power
it seems like a good bet all of this
twin imagery is pointing to these as yet
absent sons wanda's abrupt pregnancy at
the end of episode 2
seems to seal that particular deal
both of wandevision's first two episodes
include a fake advertisement
in episode 1 we get an ad for the
toastmate 2000.
among other things it gives us the first
indication that one division could be
taking place
in the same world as the rest of the mcu
as we find out the device is built by
stark
industries the all-new toastmate 2000
by stark industries the toastmate 2000
is also a clever reference to both
vision and wanda's comic book twin sons
vision is after all wanda's mate and
like the toaster he's part machine the
toaster of course
creates two matching pieces of toasted
bread
just like wanda and vision's matching
twin boys
and who makes the toast mate 2000 stark
industries just like how it's tony stark
who is one of vision's creators in
avengers age of ultron
there are a lot of allusions to witches
and witchcraft in one division which is
fitting considering wanda's alter ego is
the scarlet
witch one such easter egg is part of the
format for the one division show within
a show
at the end of both of the first two
wandavision episodes the couple is
framed in a hexagon as the end credits
role
that's not something commonly seen in
sitcoms of any era
one explanation is that it's referencing
wanda's powers
while we've never heard them described
this way in the mcu movies or tv shows
in the comics wanda's ranged blasts are
called hex spheres not to mention that a
hex
commonly means a spell or curse cast by
a witch
when agnes takes it upon herself to help
wanda create a memorable romantic
evening in episode 1
she uses tips from a woman's magazine
called glamorous
now you could understandably assume
there's nothing much to make of that
title
until we get to episode 2. wanda and
vision volunteer to be part of the
talent show benefiting west view
elementary and they put on a magic act
vision plays the magician and wanda
plays his lovely assistant
glamour i am glamour and he's an
illusion
this is yet another reference to
witchcraft well usually when we talk
about glamour we're talking about
someone's attractiveness or their
lifestyle
there's another meaning for the word a
glamour can also mean a mystical
enchantment
in particular it's typically an illusion
for a perfect mcu example
think of loki when loki disguises
himself as someone else
that would be called a glamour and
considering how much you come to
question the reality of what's going on
in one division
that word carries some weight in the
final moments of one division's premiere
episode we pull back from the screen
showing the sitcom to see a desk
the screen playing the faux sitcom is
surrounded by much more contemporary
technology
and someone whose face we don't see is
sitting and watching this strange show
more importantly on the monitor to the
left of the tv screen and on a notepad
on the desk
we see a symbol familiar to marvel
comics fans the symbol with the blade as
the picture suggests
belongs to an organization called sword
whose acronym in the comics
stands for sentient world observation
and response department
the agency is first revealed in joss
whedon and
john cassaday's astonishing x-men run
when they're introduced as the space
counterpart to shield
while shield deals with earthbound
threats sword handles threats from the
stars
fans have been theorizing about the mcu
sword for years
and the symbols at the end of episode 1
let us know they're finally here
if you're familiar with the hit sitcom
bewitched starring elizabeth montgomery
as a witch who both uses her powers to
solve her family's problems and
struggles to keep her identity as a
witch secret
it's impossible to not think of the show
while watching wandavision
it comes to mind early in the premiere
episode when wanda is putting her dishes
away with her telekinetic powers
but the similarities get kicked up a
notch in the opening credits of episode
2 when instead of using the dick van
dyke show for inspiration
wandavision uses animation reminiscent
of bewitch's unique style
it's a particularly fitting show to
choose to pull from for episode 2 for a
few reasons
one of the most obvious is the fact that
both shows deal with witchcraft
another is that just as episode 2 ends
with the world of wanda vision changing
from black and white to
color bewitched began its life as a
black and white show in 1964
and changed to color in 1966
[Music]
early in episode 2 we get color mixed in
with the black and white
and it's as striking as it is meaningful
after practicing the magic act with
vision
wanda is straightening up the living
room when she hears a whirring and a
bang from outside
in the bushes of her front yard she
finds a toy helicopter
unlike everything else in this black and
white world the helicopter shows some
color
it's red and gold with some metallic
silver mixed in
the number 57 is on its side and the
sword symbol is painted on the front
the number on the helicopter isn't
randomly chosen the first comic book
appearance of the vision comes in 1968's
avengers number 57
and once again just as the toastmate
2000 reminds us of tony stark
for some reason or another the
helicopter happens to be painted
in iron man's classic colors like the
premiere wanda vision episode the second
episode treats us to another
faux advertisement this time instead of
a toaster we get a watch
manufactured by a company called
strucker and the commercial is chock
full of easter eggs
first there's the most obvious reference
baron von strucker
whose short mcu life ends with avengers
age of ultron
is in charge of the experiments which
give wanda and her late brother pietro
their powers
he's a part of hydra whose sinister logo
is visible
on the watch face aligned as they are
the watch hands can't help but bear a
resemblance to loki's scepter
from which wanda and pietro's powers
spring
then there's the time the watch is
showing the time of 242
and if you're looking for easter eggs in
marvel media pay attention to numbers
consequentially 1984's avengers number
242
is a pretty important one for the team
and for vision and scarlet witch in
particular
the pair are reunited when vision's body
finally is restored after
injuries he'd suffered during a previous
adventure
early in episode 2 wanda and vision
practiced their magic
act for the talent show in the living
room and later we get to see that act
completely go
off the rails when swallowing a piece of
chewing gum messes with vision's
insides so much that he acts like a
raving drunk
is this god is this guy what is it
in both scenes we also see what vision
calls the cabinet of mysteries
equipped with a secret door to let its
occupant seem to have disappeared
adorning the cabinet is a picture of the
mine stone stuck to vision's head
it's not just an easter egg but a
meaningful reference
after all we still don't know how or why
vision
isn't dead or why the mind stone is with
him his mind stone was destroyed off
camera by thanos
and the stone from the past was
presumably returned by captain america
the purpose of the cabinet as a device
to make things disappear
and reappear might also have some
significance after all
both the mind stone and vision are
things that were supposed to disappear
but didn't at least not completely
when wanda and dottie confront each
other in the middle of episode 2
the 1965 hit single help me rhonda
by the beach boys is playing on a nearby
radio
it may seem like a song chosen just
because of the era
until you think about both the name of
the song and some of the lyrics
first of all there's the title rhonda
sounds a lot like
wanda then there's what the beach boys
are singing on the surface the song is
about a man devastated by his fiancee
cheating on him and asking ronda to get
her out
of his heart but if you think of it in
the context of vision
and wanda's shared history it becomes a
much darker story
particularly with these lyrics she was
gonna be my wife
and i was gonna be her man but she let
another guy come between us
and it shattered our plants the last
thing vision and want to talk about
before being attacked by the black order
in avengers infinity war
is making their relationship more
permanent then
another guy i.e thanos shatters not only
their plans
but literally shatters vision
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]